i think the only screenwriting tip that  i would have that me and simon have  tried to do with each of the films is  like absolutely  plot it all out kind of like we try to  plot it out on one sheet of paper so we  actually made this kind of like line of  like the sort this is the axe structure  and these are the 12 pubs so this is  going to happen at this point and this  is going to happen at this point so very  sort of methodical and mathematical  about it because it can be a difficult  thing if you're writing without a clear  idea of where you're going to go  and in fact you know with most of the  films um certainly with sean and with um  world's end a very very clear idea of  what the final scene was  um and and what that final image was  gonna be  so  you know it's good to know where you're  heading so that you don't get lost and  bored along the way